let's go to aaron from los angeles aaron
welcome to the show
hi david uh i just wanted to ask a quick
question regarding um i guess i don't
know if intellectual copyright is the
term um but there's been like i've been
reading a lot of articles regarding i
guess like bill gates and just to be
clear i am not an anti-vaxxer okay i
mean like i'm triple backs boosted and
everything so before i go into this i
just want to say that
i understand that bill gates is a source
of a controversy when it becomes um i
guess like intellectual property and
copyright like he has been getting
involved in a scandal regarding of
vaccines not being distributed to the
global south as quickly as they should
be and a lot of people are identifying
this as a major reason the covet 19
pandemic isn't slowing down i was
wondering what could our congress do
to perhaps reform our intellectual
copyright laws to prevent i guess big
pharmaceutical companies from
preventing you know necessary access to
vaccines
well with it with vaccines specifically
the desire has been
for
the
vaccines to to essentially
not be protected by copyright or
intellectual prop patent protections and
just to be basically allowed to be open
sourced and produced anywhere
and there was a brief period where
modernist said we still have our patent
but we're not necessarily going to
enforce it and you know i i don't know
ultimately what happened with that
there's a number of different issues
going on with vaccine distribution but i
i just i'm not exactly sure
with vaccines specifically it's one set
of problems
bigger picture there's all sorts of
other intellectual property issues that
that exist and would be dealt with in
different ways so i i'm just i'm just
not sure how to address the question
okay uh yeah it's just i know that bill
gates has been tied up with intellectual
property rights even since like his
foundation of microsoft in the 1990s i
mean as a matter of fact before he was
getting into philanthropy a lot of the
controversies that he had regarding
microsoft's monopoly on the software
industry were really one of the things
that he was best known for yeah that was
the big issue about the bundling of
internet explorer with windows in which
he gave you know hours and hours of
pretty pretty uh
notable
depositions and uh yeah you're
absolutely right but i to be perfectly
frank i don't know that bill gates is
the biggest player right now in what's
going on with vaccines
okay i understand yeah um yeah i i know
that it's just like in regards to
philanthropy i i understand that he he
does have a lot of influence with it i i
just think that like maybe the extent
could be overstated as a result of like
you know the various conspiracy theories
that are around him right now but i i
guess that is just something i want to
look into i it's just i i honestly just
think that
if we don't slow down the effects of the
kova 19 pandemic you know in the global
south we're going to continue to see
these variants and i don't really i
don't know if it's going to lead to
another shutdown but i do think it's
definitely going to lead to a spread of
the infection yep and we're seeing cases
go up now and hopefully it won't become
a major spike but uh a point well said
and and well taken i appreciate the call
very much
glad we could speak to a few people
today thanks to our guests bailing on us
we'll still take the broader calls for
our friday show we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this